article dessus
n'hésitez pas toutes les commandes vous
les avez dans le jeu pendant le dans la
barre du titre du live elles sont là
pour vous pour vous faciliter la vie et
que ça pue fait pour vous on va passer
maintenant sur le dernier joueur on va
sur le prospect nba qui arrive qui
gagnerait alors on va mettre sa page
dans le temps que met la page voilà qui
gagnent ouais c'est le la star daliot à
cette année et qui a malheureusement
perdu hier contre wichman comme tu
l'avais annoncé et donc on ne le reverra
plus jamais sur le maillot des occases
et avant de commencer je sais pas si tu
te rappelles me dois faire un mea culpa
est ce que tu te souviens pourquoi
parce que je voulais pas le mettre dans
l'article des intérieurs à suivre avant
la saison et que j'ai est allé glisser
le nom c'est ça c'est exactement alors
cette année qu'on a commencé la saison
envergure on a j'ai fait trois articles
j'ai fait trois articles sur les
meilleurs arrières à suivre les
meilleurs ailiers a suivi les meilleurs
qui vous à suivre qui ont déjà ce
qu'était notre tournoi est de retour et
seniors et je retire les ailiers on
avait huit à neuf noms cei et on hésite
et sur le dernier en tout cas je suis
allé demander à l'anneau son conseil sur
le dernier j'ai fait un peu le nombre de
la team et tout est animé 10 mai que tu
devrais mettre qui gagnent murray et je
me suis dit mme webb qui aimeraient moi
je vais pas
l'un des plus à l'époque effectivement
pas s comme pour gaza
j'avais toujours me sentais du projet
thomas dumorey j'avais préféré alan
mulally gagnent je crois à l'avant après
ce style là et je t'avais dit sur what's
up bon si je devais y fait une énorme
saison et qu'il est l'autre hippique
belge serait mon mea culpa en live et je
passerais petit j'assumerai il se trouve
messieurs dames que keegan murray fait
une excellente saison qui tour à tour
notre conférence à plus de 28 points de
moyenne et que tout le monde en parle
comme le triptyque donc c'est le moment
de le faire mais coupat et et de dire
que ben j'aurais du jour et du jour et
du maître qui est demeurée la prochaine
fois l'année prochaine quand on leur
fera jeter coûterait
façon qu'un mot à dire
unanime et sans aucune discussion
il joué 18 minutes l'an dernier
est en fait moi je trouve que c'est mais
le procès est plus intéressant de
l'équipe pas rare que j'adore oui ce
camp où sont déjà tu feras nourrissent
coup vraiment c'était un mes joueurs
préférés je suis moi mon sport aux
spurs jouent pas malheureusement les jo
jo dégâts et il reste quinze matches
complètement complètement mais met en
fête qui gagnent des qui rentrait va
situerait en fait ces stats c'est stop
par 40 minutes parce que ça qu'il faut
voir à l'an dernier puisqu'il j'ai vu
qu'ils jugent que 18 minutes doit ces
trucs puis diois il a à 7 points 5
rebonds en 18 minutes ou mal mais bon en
fait ouais si tu si tu mettais les
stades sur une trentaine de minutes
c'était un joueur super productifs et
qu'ils avaient des monts pourcentage
donc moi je trouvais intéressant qui
gagnent murray devra pas se mentir mea
culpa tu le fais mais je peux pas dire
que je m'attendais à ça non plus faut
toujours mesurer
pour avoir un profil du joueur alors
vous n'avez pas scouting les portes qui
apparaît directement mais maxime avait
préparé aussi sur cette photo là c'est
pas c'est pas un photoshop c'est que
keegan murray un frère jumeau qui jouait
sein du coup d'état du mois
et qui devrait du coup devenir le leader
des prochaines des wesh carrément les
organisent alors même si thomas donc
vous pouvez s'était tout de a à z qui
avait gros sur twitter pense qu'il va la
draft lui et espère voir au second tour
chris murray moi je pense qu'il va
rester qui va devenir le jardin du roi
mais on verra on verra son choix et le
leersois des outils athlétique
en tout cas des a des arguments à faire
valoir aussi pour donner un petit peu le
profil du mec vous voyez qu'il est
classé ailier fort de mettre 03 98 kg
donc encore assez développé une
envergure de 111 cm
à toi et moi on le voit au niveau
supérieur plus comme un ailier fort qui
vaut malgré les 2 mètres 0 3 plutôt que
comme un ailier ailier forte en
quatre simples plus que 3,4 complètement
dans le style de jeu alors on a un
joueur qui a montré cette année qu'il
pouvait marquer de partout et j'ai
quelque chose à vous montrer pour ça je
fais les choses si bibi analytics qui
nous permet d'avoir les choses sur du
jeu la charte du joueur tu me dis si tu
vois bien ou pas aux cieux zoom un petit
peu
keegan murray il est en haut à gauche et
quand vous regardez sa répartie sur des
tirs vous pouvez voir qu'il est il fait
mieux que la moyenne indicielle dans
quasiment tous les secteurs de jeu à
part l'instance et le ministre vous
voyez qu'il ya un très petit un peu très
petit échantillon dans les tirs pris
dans laxe ça mais que 73% près du cercle
avec deux centrales de 134 tentative
donc un gros volume et à trois points
hormis dans les corners on est à plus de
40 % qu encore une fois un énorme boule
émission soixante sites s'est repris
pour toute la saison et on va aller
regarder du film mais tu me dis si je me
trompe en termes le tir à 3 propre prix
on allait
globalement deux séquences majoritaire
soit katia tout en finition en bout de
chaîne
je suis un profil de piquionne pop où je
vais écarter le jeu et c'est sur ce
profil là qu on a une projection poste 5
1 dans 16 en nba
concrètement mais sur ces gens qui
pourra punir les miss match un joueur
qui m'impressionne dans un kite saf lui
sa fluidité quand même pour sa taille au
match contre si je me suis fait des deux
matches deux tournois de conférence
finale demi-finale les trois points
qu'il arrive à mettre en mouvement la
compréhension qu'il agit avec clips et
ce à la compression qui l'a ensuite de
comment les défenses vont réagir est ce
qu'il est capable de fax en posant le
ballon au sol atteint clause out à sa
taille son poids son gabarit vraiment
très intéressé bon début d'année je ne
voyais plus que je devrais vraiment dans
le moule brandonnet clark il ya un
finisseur super fort
sur tout ce qui est flatteur second
rideau
second saut et il est vraiment ajouter
de tir extérieur sur volume cette année
c'est pas juste un tiers extérieurs
c'est à dire à l'extérieur sur volume il
ya quasiment 39% à 3 points 3 sur 4 3
points par match et vite ses limites
donc cinq poissons
à deux réussites
86% catch and shoot donc on voit que
c'est un jour qui finit quasi
exclusivement prochaine décisif en bout
de chaîne c'est 30% de saison donc c'est
un tiers de ces tirs et donc comme tu
l'as dit c'est un très très gros volumes
il en a pris 166 sur l'année à ce moment
là c'est très conséquent tout en étant
largement le leader offensif de l'équipe
tu vois qui prend deux fois plus de tirs
que le deuxième qui est john brennan qui
est un qui est le plus gros tireurs à
trois pour atteindre 2 volumes de
l'histoire de d'aquitaine du canal ni le
plus elle même temps ça fait six ans
qu'il est là bah oui c'est je t'ai pas
dit le contraire se dit que c'est pas
très bonnes âmes et nous voilà en terme
de différence d'écart tu prends goût la
troupe deuxième et troisième option et
tu fais le cumul et ça fait le nombre de
tirs comprend qu'il va demeurer
maintenant
je vais me mettre le chat en même temps
pour regarder un petit peu ce que ça dit
tout me rées les super rocher l'erika il
peut sembler le mettre à niveau naturel
bordure 5 alors on va la regarder nos
mac donough bourde ou est ce qu'on l'a
juste avant on finit vite fait les stats
on voit que c'est un joueur qui prend 40
personnes s'est hier près du panier
71 5 % de réussite ce qui est excellent
vous l'avez vu le soir juste avant alors
que la majorité de ces tirs sont pris
par lui même en fait pas issu d'une
passe décisive et que lorsqu'il va au
cercle une fois sur deux il obtient
assez régulièrement des lancers-francs
donc c'est un joueur qui est assez
agressif et qui fait tomber des fautes
et les à 74% ont aussitôt lancé france
piller correcte sans être très vite et
enfin tu as un petit volume à deux
points vous l'avez vu jouer à chooz
charts que c'est plus je vois les sur la
ligne de fond sur le côté gauche côté
droit plutôt que dans l'axé il ya très
peu de poules up en sortie de en sortir
car on est vraiment plus sûr de la ligne
de fond il a dû toucher avec un petit
flotteur ou à quelque chose dans ce
style
avant deux pendant que moi je peux
émettre prendre le le board toi ou est
ce que tu lui si tu pourquoi tu le
situer ce niveau là et est ce que tu as
tu as évolué par rapport au début de
saison
ouais je les perds 3 aussi
c'est un genre je referai entre 10 et 15
je pense parce que j'ai pour moi un
trait au plancher l'igad murray c'est ce
qui va m'apporter et le tir extérieur le
fait que puisse être potentiellement un
des uns des noms shooter sur le terrain
fait que vraiment mais est hanté par qui
gagneraient plus qu'avant avant j'étais
pas tellement de tir on va dire qu'entre
way entre 10 et 15 je peux je peux dire
c'est qu'ils gagnent mur et je suis je
plus dans le train qu'avant car l'ont
alors on voit par rapport à la dernière
fois toi je crois que tu es honteuse de
troy d'un thé ou toi tu es en quatrième
sur la liste est rien donc quelque 9
milliards us il est 14e et toi tu l'as
du coup
les 11e et dans mon tiers qui va de 6 à
15 ans quelque chose comme ça en fait
shannon qui va de shannon sharpe à alger
dès mardi donc
ces gens là sont dans le même tiers et
qui est demeuré est installé deux au
hockey moi je l'est un peu plus bas pour
l'instant
il est monté en déjà mis va encore un
peu monter au fur et à mesure je les 21e
alors qu'est-ce qui toi tu empêches
mètres plus haut et je pense qu'on va
avoir des similitudes et savent
expliquer pour moi pourquoi moi je les
aussi bas pourquoi est ce qu'il n'est
pas dans ton tiers de et pourquoi est ce
qu'il est peut-être au début tout tir 3
ou vers 6 7
parce que
le manque de le manque de place de
plafonds je pense est de pouvoir de
création balle en main pour moi ce sera
un très solide joueur de rotation plus
plus un bon titulaire
un genre de fin de chaîne efficace je
vois pas le plafond de joueurs donc ça
reste à droite parce que on donnera au
potentiel donc
dans le top 10 c'est pas vraiment le
genre que j'apprécie ce mais
j'appréciais incroyablement mais force
est de constater que je vais le mettre
assez de place et
alors mais en fait on est à peu près le
même constat
personnellement je trouve l'accès à ces
moyens
pour le niveau nba j'aime bien le
comparer alors là c'est qu'ils les
comprennent ça vaut ce que ça vaut
toujours donc ce n'est pas hyper fan
mais j'aime bien le comparer une sorte
de hobby topping mais qui sauteraient
moins
j'aime alors il tire mieux que 8e que ce
comité au pin faisait mais je trouve que
le dribble est très haut donc je crois
pas qu'ils puissent créer ballon
et défensivement parlant je trouve qu'il
est assez sûr côté notre ami tianli
parce qu'on est écrié on décrit souvent
un défenseur hyper polyvalent capable de
switcher sur 4 5 postes
et là dessus moi je suis pas du tout
d'accord je trouve que le cayenne murray
élan latéralement qui est là en grosse
difficulté genre de changements d'appuis
et qu'à chaque fois qu'on le conte le
fait défendre des extérieurs il est
battu et auquel du coup comme c'est un
poste 4 et qu'on va va être amené à
devoir faire des switchs parce que pour
le coup les postes 4 switch sur les
extérieurs en nba quand il ya des pick
and roll ou des démarquages doigts du
ballon moi là dessus je suis assez
inquiet et comme tu l'as dit en termes
de potentialités comme je ne crois pas
pour porter la malle mais mixer un rôle
de finition bajeux le bassin petit peu
maintenant il va sûrement remonter parce
que c'est quand même un vrai sniper et
si pour l'instant il est derrière les
loges les travaux qu'ils aient
finalement peut-être les wendell moore
il va peut-être passer devant me va pas
gagner énormément et je vais la voir
peut-être 15-17 croque six mois entre 15
et 20 kw à quoi et ouais je pense et
c'est le genre de deux de rennes joue il
va arriver dans une équipe qui
veut être compétitive qui joue le clean
et qui va avoir besoin de bons joueurs
pour passer un cap et je pense qu'il
peut très vite intégré à notre temps je
pense que c'est le contexte idéal pour
lui en plus derrière donc j'espère fort
qui va pas de prix trop haut
je suis souvent les pigs et ne n'y voyez
pas une une agression personnel mais
j'espère qu'on va pas lui mettre des
grosses pressions au mode faut que tu
nous fasse passer un cap des équipes
n'ont plié aux fables
l'équipe de playoffs je pense que c'est
juste un bon joueur supplémentaire cote
ajoute
autoporteur aussi et qui va de perdre
d'avoir des objectifs un peu plus élevé
de retard meilleur
complètement jugé dakar est jeune et
plus haut parce que je vois pas non plus
des airs incroyable potentiel le porteur
de balle dans la cuve et donc je suis je
suis forcé de le mettre un peu plus haut
mais j'ai un peu déçu de djeddah nardi
kyle chandler n'étaient pas non plus
donc le profil que je préfère donc ces
gens là auraient dû et pour être devant
mais je tiens à un trait au plancher qui
n'est pas à négliger comme qu'il ya une
réponse il ya un truc hong kong ou d'isf
au stade est en fait on se rend compte
de la faiblesse relative de la draf en
termes de potentiel par le fait qu'ils
aient beaucoup beaucoup de sophomore
généraux
moi depuis que je suis la draft il ya
j'ai rarement vu autant de sophomore
junior squatter la loterie quoi parmi
les trucs on voit alors je vais prendre
le consensus plutôt que la mienne parce
que voilà mais john elle vit sophomore
jonathan davies sophomore
bénédicte mature à turin qui gagnent le
ouais sauf mort donc et moi j'étais loin
de ces brawn par exemple qui est sauf
moi aussi walker keskar sophomore
jacques badji junior donc on allait le
draft avec beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
peur que la semaine et ça ça prouve
qu'on n'a pas des sénans potentialités
par rapport aux jets prendre deux
joueurs
par rapport à john allan davis et auch
avec badji
qui sont tous les trois des porteurs de
baleines sea the stars de leur équipe
scoreur j'aurai les postes est lié
comment tu le compares et entente de
plafonds planchers potentialités
je suis pas plus grand fan de nintendo
wii
et nds quand je vous conte du top 5 et
j'ai un peu de mal je vois pas la clé
ouais 13
c'est dans le même tir mais
john davis chaque bagis
ce qui va faire la différence qui peut
faire la différence que sur des postes
où c'est peut-être un peu plus rares peu
importe et
pousser des progrès au tir d'un magisson
se confirme si les progrès balle en main
aussi de jonathan davies se confirme
puisque jason davis est un mix entre ces
quantités super chaud cette année et
maintenant puisque maintenant il a un
peu blessé donc c'est pas vraiment le
droit de jonathan 10 jeux d'athènes
davis qui vit qui laisse une réussite
incroyable sur des poulets contesté à
deux points ça va te coucher j'ai du mal
à croire que ça puisse continuer donc
c'est que c'est des joueurs qui peuvent
être liés parce que cech bagis là deux
ans de plus aux initiés que qui
gagnerait maison que trois mois d'écart
donc en fait et chaque mot chaque bagis
c'est pas il a pas l'âge d'un seigneur
et qui gagnent murray hill à paladin
sophomore donc pour plus que sauf au
mental l'âge aussi très important je
t'aime davis 1 en mouvement c'est ce
soir là
voilà je lui commence à toi donc c'est
tout ça est à prendre en compte parce
que chaque budget pour ceux qui ne le
savent pas et commencent le basket il a
15 ans qu'à 16 ans aujourd'hui je n'a
alors toi je vais te dire ça il va
falloir quand même deux ouais tu as
vingt deux ans donc il axe étant de
basket donc effectivement c'est un sale
est d'humeur il est très très jeune dans
son basket alors après là encore plus
développé mois la diff que je vais faire
et pourquoi jésus hatton davis qui passe
devant ac bâti et
pourquoi d'evra de dévisser même tir
pour ma collègue badji et j
notre ami kane murray un peu derrière
parce que zlatan débit c'est
effectivement je crois plus en tant que
porteur de balle il m'a montré beaucoup
de choses au début la neige arrivée
parce dans le vague moi j'ai fait un +15
parce que je me suis bouffer tous ses
matches et qu'on m'a donné voilà le la
capacité à a dribblé aussi bien changé
de direction pouvoir pour la paix tout
j'ai été séduit et angie pour moi peut
jouer des deux côtés d'une certaine
façon élite
là où kia ne n'arrive pas j'arrive pas
être convaincu quoi
complètement enfin pour comprendre la
petite chatte harrison tu l'as plus haut
parce que je pense que toi il ya des
similitudes offensive avait entre les
deux joueurs mais ils sont éteints
peut-être un meilleur athlète et un
meilleur prospect défensif et wikango
est ce qui le fait passer pour toi
peut-être devant
moi c'est le deuxième mais s'il n'y a
pas de château laurens est le meilleur
défenseur de cette barre ok mais chez
tom renney crois énormément dans le nord
ce mot la scalabilité de de taris
sonnent comme de jérémy soran je peux
les jeux peu léger des voix dans plein
de intensément plein de
deux contextes sont toujours utiles
des dégâts qui peuvent défendre 3-4-5
switcher sur des plus petits comme le
pays seules ou comme le fait social par
moments mais t'es tu cherches voilà je
le vois je les vois plus utile plus plus
fort que
que
murray qu'il fait davis
ouais on se retourne on s'entend
là-dessus mode
marathon je la gardais mais je vais pas
faire un marathon comme j'aime bien
faire d'habitude et enfin lorsque que je
m'y mettre sérieusement et jérémy
sereine pour le coup c'est plus ma ma
came habituel et je te rejoins je te
rejoins sur le film que j'ai pris d'iowa
alors vous allez voir que c'est un peu
si je fais des playlists et tout mais
comme ce soir je savais qu'on allait
faire aux autres gros joueurs j'avoue
que j'ai tout mis en même temps parce
que je les passais trop long ça fait
déjà quasiment deux ans et demi qu'on a
lancé live donc 2h prendre
ce que j'aime de regarder chez guyane le
jeu cannois c'est la polyvalence au
niveau du tir on l'a dit dit yann pop
fin de chaîne et il ya un petit peu de
couleur à
dire qui est assez compact tu vois les
pieds des kopa beaucoup du sol uni en
termes de bras sa part est passée banc
mais avec une grosse efficacité
ce que je vous invite pas mal à regarder
c'est quand il va au stack moi je trouve
que si jamais le défenseur en face de
lui arrive à résister à son son impact
physique supérieur ou n'diaye bah à ce
moment là nuit il est en grande
difficulté et c'est pour ça que haut
niveau elle bien je ne crois pas en tant
que porteur de balle et défensivement
j'essaie de montrer des bonnes séquences
il encaisse de comptes actifs et des
très bonnes rotations je trouve mais
qu'il est souvent battus sur des
changements de direction des
accélérations
dîner ce que ce qu'on peut dire aussi
voilà c'est que la défoncer tout le
monde en fait ce début d'année dans les
matches entre conférences ou ayew avait
mis à calandre est simple pour boire
beaucoup de matches faciles à faire mon
teint pour le record de l'équipe et il
est mon co donc moi en fait tu attendais
le voir dans les lobbys l'image du big
ten et le match du virginia là c'est
l'un des premiers bons fait soit 6,0 à
ce moment-là et six matches qui gagne
avant ces six équipes de mythes des
genres voire lo mejor donc c'est pour ça
que aussi un mois j'étais un petit peu
peut-être plus frileux sur le début
d'année qui m'a convaincu sur le big ten
là elle tourne un habitant ouais j'ai
pris alors un match où tout début donné
parce qu en fait les clips que j'ai là
c'est un des premiers live que j'ai fait
sur la chaîne on avait fait le premier
ensemble avec on avait parlé de
vannes une hausse que de scotty band
souvent de mauvais jours avec chopin
noblet jian tong a way et à crazy heart
et
on va donc j'avais fait celui-là on
deuxième avec chamois tchatchoua jours
john hopkins etc et il y avait à ce
moment là comme j'avais dit sur les jeux
sur les réseaux lors du derby avait
moins de monde forcément c'était les
balbutiements et j'ai rajouté du film
lors des matchs de conférences aussi on
avait de l'adversité on est du coup sûr
la fin de fin de saison et j'aimais bien
de voir l'évolution du joueur rentre là
le début la fif au contenu le pouvoir
comment il a grandi et il a un nez de
plus en plus de polyvalence dans son tir
par contre en terme de défaut garde à
peu près les mêmes
c'est pas un jour qui va
alors vous voyez la prime sur le dribble
haut on est face à pour zhu
je le remets à celui d'avant le dribbler
trop on essaie de faire un hôtel on ne
peut pas c'est pas c'est pas ça casse
pas sa gamme
il se fait intercepter être facilement
et ce genre de choses là font que moi je
n'arrive pas le maître top 5 des hommes
disent comme pouvait la voir la plupart
des je pense que les gens qui fument
être top 5 c'est les mêmes gens qui
mettait à l'époque hobbit au pin up
ceinture
moi j'étais pareil deux grands fans
depuis deux péniches ne veulent avoir 16
17 je crois plus sain qui gagnent murray
parce que je compose dans le tir de
keegan murray je pense que défensivement
il n'a pas les problèmes et que vont
kkobbi topping mais je voi
oued et par contre 8 les délires de
l'enfant tchenko jour de fin de chaîne
quelque chose comme ça là on voit il
part ma gauche spin move est hyper le
contrôle encore une fois
alors quand quand on me dit créateur
balle en main ou ne pas non pour moi
c'est un joueur qui va peut-être être
efficace genre troll mais qui nous qui
ne prendra pas le dessus de loin alors
pour elle le fait de ouais c'est pas
dans son arsenal donc
je réponds à beaucoup d'écrits un jour
qui le film dépeint
l'armée on voit une trappe quand je dis
problèmes-là de latéralité c'est que
dans l'exécution dans les apps ou les
petits changements de direction il n'est
pas capable de faire donc c'est un mec
qui va se faire splitté donc il va se
faire prendre latéralement
et on voit là alors hop sur la victime
son amante je fais une pause vite fait
contre contre porto en finale voilà il a
mis 28 points avec 61 % de réussite aux
tirs et 8 heures du 3e tournoi
exceptionnel même s'il se fait sortir au
premier touriste fait j'ai pas vu le
match où je le regarde ripley mon époux
est ce que vas tu as répondu qu'on est
avec rémy réversion en live hier mais
pour ceux qui n'étaient pas là est ce
que le fait qu'ils se fassent sortir au
premier tour et qui se passait peut-être
étant le leader de l'équipe ça peut
louer négativement sur sa crainte
non je pense pas honnêtement je pense
pas pourquoi prendre en compte
un match sur 35 alors oui c'est
peut-être que moi je suis plus important
mais c'est un sport collectif le basket
c'est pas assez par individu et là il
n'ya pas cela pas avoir été bon il est
pas de cela équipe ii richement une
équipe sous côté ciné meilleures équipes
de 2002 mais genre
expérimenté et un peu construite pour
faire du mal en mars d'ailleurs ils vont
le faire parce qu'ils vont pas s'arrêter
là j'espère mais
et non je mangeais ce cocktail qui perd
quand oregon state l'an dernier je vais
pas dire assez c'est un looser et prenez
6 devant puisque seulement au final les
comptes etc sont pas les mêmes et la
vérité sont pas les mêmes donc il est
façon en plus c'est pas un porteur de
balle qui gagnent donc il ya aussi il
est aussi dépendre la création de ces
extérieur et indépendant de la du
comment on va le mettre en bonne
position il est dépendant si dexia des
pertes de balle bête de ses adversaires
baisse de ces deux spectacles phares
dont il n'a pas le et c'est pas le
métronome du jeu qui gagnera c'est le
finisseur ultime puissant une sieste
anas a alors le voit en transition
capable de t'avoir une belle fille pas
des jours qu'on envoie une pièce au
capable de te faire ça là on voit encore
un pitch and pop qui va être plus ce
jour de variétés après cinq jours qui
les aiment bien aussi jouer post baky
qui est demandeur du ballon
par contre sur le côté effectivement là
le à nice comme à spa ne se définit pas
une saison j'ai totalement d'accord
aussi et on le disait avec rémy avait
rejoué et en général
globalement les équipes nba elles se
font elles font pas leurs avis par
rapport au moc du grand public elles se
feront leur avis quand elles verront le
joueur et toi tu disais aussi les scouts
là ils connaissent les marqueurs
lamarthe menacer la survie sur le gâteau
mais ça ne rapportera pas grand chose de
plus en veine nation qu'est ce qu'ils
ont pu voir depuis le début de saison
souvent la march madness moi je dis
c'est que c'est plus en fait des joueurs
ou que tu as peut-être pas vu pas assez
vu ils font une grosse marche madness et
tu dis ok je vais aller revoir pour
aller revoir avant parce que ne jamais
surcoté l'échantillon de quatre cinq six
matches sur un échantillon parfois deux
ou trois saisons à laquelle richardson
n'oublie jamais malaquais richardson
brigitte baptiste
oui parce que c'est un art au premier
tour alors que pour sa march madness
donc
il faut ce qui fait la beauté du tournoi
mais moi j'ai pas envie de me faire
avoir donc
non je prendrais pas à pas de temps
contre ce qui se passe par contre c'est
un joueur je le vois sur deux trois
quatre matches groupe chose je vais de
revoir ce que j'ai fait sur gleeden l'an
dernier en fait tu te rendais compte que
jude s'était pas juste la march madness
qui était une fois le l'an dernier
toutes les malts pack toile où était
déjà incroyable donc
puis ça à lui il est super bon sur ce
compte et ça va je vais les revoir c'est
comme ça que je fonctionne
pour être moi la note vande c'est
peut-être les matchs que je vois le nom
saison c'est le pour nous un prix avec
mon final on apprendra par la draft mais
en tant de tournois séjour le gros
moment et tout
et en fait par le fait qu'ils aient
autant de matches et que moi m'est avis
sur les joueurs sont déjà assez fait vu
que j'essaie d'avoir vu un maximum de
gamme avant la march madness évidemment
un bonus où je deviens un peu
spectateurs fans je me fais des manches
au fil des matches complètement et
décroche un peu du côté scouting report
est tout
d'autant que c'est des matches voilà
pour le coup j'ai très très peu de
scouts de sr qui sont faits sur de la
march madness
pareil moi je suis c'est à dire lundi
quasiment le seul match que je m'attends
live denis siège le fait qu un replay
quasiment que ça soit moins chronophage
donc là je suis un spectateur je profite
alors grade avec des amis même qui me le
diras tu tu aimes bien lui tu connais
bah oui je connais j'ai vu toute l'année
tu vois que
c'est plus un rôle à avoir la vie des
gens qui connaissent pas trop ça fait un
peu une gagnons c'est des trucs puis et
ça a été différent fait moi pour mes
potes actuellement la plus grosse star
de la banda c'est la pomme par la
thyroïde wayne indiana
les braises comprend
nouveau look pour qu'ils gagnent on va
gagner c'est du coup des questions de
lutte en faire un peu le bilan du profil
ailier amené à jouer post 4 postes cinq
joueurs de pitch and pop finisseur de
bout de chaîne
on n'a pas trop parlé du tuy mais c'est
un joueur avec qui s'est toujours très
bien se passer des deux côtés du terrain
athlète je trouve assez moyens notamment
médicalement et latéralement
ouais et par contre qui aura sûrement de
voir trois contre et en nba parce que le
plancher comme tu le disais aussi état
c'est assez bon
on a une bonne question la petite tu
veux si tu veux que je prenne en main il
ya une bonne question sur qui gagnent
une personne qui nous dit laisse pas de
doute ils ont faussé un peu et donc
pourquoi pas apprendre les restes à
poulets problème c'est que quand tu vas
avoir le spic de keegan mois sur sport
référence donc sur la saison complète il
a 23 ans 23,9 et en conférence il est en
23 8 5 donc en fait les stades sont pas
réellement faussé parce que mon bac je
confirme donc 17 matches de conférences
shoot à 53% au tir 42 % à 3 points il
est en 23 8 5 sur la saison ils iront
23.5 qui shoote à 55% 39% à 3 points
tout même mieux à trois points sur les
matchs de conférences que sur la saison
global donc en fait la raison tu as
vraiment raison mais pour leucate qui
calmerait à va pas parce qu'on fait sur
toute la saison il a été trop fois il ya
eu une blessure au mieux de saison aussi
donc il a eu lieu
il a hissé le cheville qui siphonnent
l'équipe eux jouent sur lui et l'équipe
2 perd sans lui donc c'est toujours
aussi intéressant de voir comment une
équipe fonctionne sans son joueur
vedette ces guinéens sur la remplacer
l'équipe perd sans lui il a mis un peu
de temps revenir et puis après il a tout
explosé sur la fin de saison et est très
très bon
tous quelque soit notre question je
pense qu'à man est une indication mental
est pas technique choix c'est en règle
la saison régulière et suffisante oui
c'est sûr tous les matchs de conférences
surtout quand tu es nijmeijer
parce que si on regarde la saison
écourtée pas de patrick baldwin ou de
jam twenty ya quelques années finalement
les matches les plus intéressants c'est
des matches où ils ont pu y jouer hors
conférence contre des rimes et d'or est
donc cette année patrick baldwin
colorado florida et qu'est ce qu'on a vu
c'est qui s'est fait défoncer dès qu'un
prospect de sa taille qui peut lui
rendre un peu genre sont rois
il a jedi padawan qui nous demandaient
ce que c'est spécifique à l'ouest chc
général
ce n'est pas spécifique à moi est à des
joueurs qui sont à leur conférence
domine dominé après un petit peu valeur
ce samedi minuit c'est plus révélateur
de la force offensive qui était qui
gagne le reste année sur situe pour
l'exemple parce qu'on a parlé déjà
plusieurs fois cet homme que jeanne par
exemple
sur les matchs de conférence 1 que les
matchs hors conférence il a défoncé des
équipes feront d'hommes jour pixi state
mais on a été louée line ou du
monumental aussi la sortie des
performances exceptionnelles
il a aussi les mémoires très bon contre
duke très bon contre texas tech un peu
moins beaucoup de texas et même tenter
sketches et chansons ne sont pas tombés
37-13 rappaz n'a pas demandé le débat
minutes ou donc donc complètement mais
c'est vrai que les stades de tchétchènes
en ewc c'est sûr qu'elle sur 14 matches
s'essayant 15 11 4 4 c'est pas les
passes et les contraint
donc donc voilà près du cercle hier soir
chez tresquois effet quoi de 19 6 7 7
pour un truc comme ça
chet oui je crois qu'il fait quatre
interceptions 5 blocs non ouais il 5 pas
si fait 5 passes et 7 contour est
il de marie va jouer contre eux contre
26 avec le temps
ça va être assez cool comme mode avec
mes fils qui a sorti pour l'asic les a
défoncé en première mi temps c'était
assez impressionnant
alors par contre le match ou alors
attendez je suis désolé mais capillaire
bon ça va pas du tout là c'est
dégueulasse le le match contre blues dis
moi j'ai pu voir que des matches j'ai je
crois pas avoir pour que je suis pilote
est ce qu'il est blessé ou pas notre ami
juge américain non mais si on fait
beaucoup tourner mais money a joué avec
memphis donc
c'était pas été assez déçu de boyzie
j'aime bien boys ils ont un vrai
prospects billet je pense dans leur
équipe un bouquet qu'ubs était pas
mauvais sur la deuxième mi temps mais
bonne victoire pour moi
c'est toujours la même chose et manga
ouai puisons rien ay l'on en perde deux
mains et monier jets se sont déjà joués
c'était un des meilleurs matches high
school et ue de que j'ai vu de ma vie
donc peut-être qu'ils se plaisent qui
rehausseront plus d'options de terre
encore serait drôle
moi ça va être à moi c'est un match que
j'ai hâte de vocht j'ai c'est peut-être
de le voir en direct celui là
je vous remets le pet actuellement parce
qu'on a un petit début de cette montre
notre dame et alabama qui se dessine
avec notre dame qui suit donc ça c'est
alex qui doivent être en train de faire
là dans cette traviata chez lui
ce serait ce pas croyable que notre dame
s'était qualifié au phosphore puis celle
là bas ma derrière même si j'avais 10 k
pour moi là bas est une équipe qui
pouvait se faire l'aube 7 parce que trop
axé sur le tir extérieur
et est-ce qu'on a autre chose en même
temps quelque chose qui avait le même
temps autres scores en direct je regarde
ça tu me dis texas virginia tech c'est
serré pour l'instant 36 34
et côté là non à émail ami qui a battu
west et du coup à deux points
donc au moins j'aurai un top 7 de
valider son bracket ça va je ne pars pas
comme un conte
noir mais c'est sûr que c'est
on n'a pas un match à duke qui va jouer
il ya pas mal de il ya va dépendre des
bons d'affrontements
ouais moi j'avoue levé 5h30 ce matin
je vais je vais je vais plutôt
tranquillement et je regarderai ça me
plaît dans le week-end pour ceux qui
veulent rien
alors qu'on a j'ai une tite notifie si
jo qui follow l'achat d'un merci à toi
de jouer bienvenue parmi notre notre
communauté de fou malade eu deux filles
pour ceux qui souhaitent regarder on
rappelle que il ya le pasi espionne
player qui eux qui couvrent l'événement
et vous avez sept jours offerts en plus
sur le moi donc ça peut être intéressant
pour la march madness
et côté been spot vous avez un match par
jour en tout cas un match par nuit en or
en vo et un match de water français
lendemain matin au replay si je dis pas
de conneries
concrètement donc voilà bon bah écoutes
je pense qu'on va on va pouvoir finir là
on a fait une très grosse session plus
de vingt quasiment 2h30 de live
y aura du replay et jean raté yes bah
oui façon la modif elle est dispo tout
de suite sur sur twitch et elle passe
sur youtube
dans la en découpage au courant de la
semaine
la seule différence c'est que sur
youtube ça permet d'avoir des rip plus
effectuer comme tu l'as dit on découpe
et donc peut-être plus plus accessible
et plus lisible et je retweete ça nous
permet de générer un peu de revenus
parce que sur youtube
les extraits qu'on utilise
malheureusement on n'a pas les moyens
d'avoir synergie nokia extrait qu'on
utilise nous appartiennent pas et donc
on s'est fait fait strike immédiatement
la monétisation alors que sur twitter on
peut récupérer 5 centimes avec des pubs
pour des mikados voilà mais globalement
c'est pas ça qui changera notre vie
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis merci
à toi là c'était hyper cool comme
d'habitude soit
d'accord et bah écoutez on vous souhaite
une bonne fin de march madness en tout
cas une un bon week-end prenez soin de
vous faites attention à vous en
échangeant verdure tous les jours sur
twitter
à temps vers gher voudrait toujours un
article scouting les portes par jour et
on va vous faire des petits débris de
maarten leyts externe et on va suivre le
tournoi jusqu'au bout
toujours ton compte perso toi aussi j'ai
été hyper actif en ce moment et joie et
du goût est assorti d des extraits des
clips etc de l'analyse toujours au top
et les gentils merci beaucoup en essonne
et puis après normalement la semaine
prochaine envergure présent en
partenariat avec un un gros médias
basket donc on a hâte de pouvoir pouvoir
vous revoir sur un plus gros médias
basket et sinon se retrouveront stream
vendredi prochain et on verra de qui ont
parlé et sur quel sujet voilà des bisous
à tous prenez soin de voile and prends
soin de toi fais gaffe à s'imposer huit
de basket si jamais tu enchaînes on va
essayer d'enchaîner
alors qu'ils
auraient tous